SHARAD JONES: Hey, everyone.
Welcome back.
So in today's video, we're
going to switch gears.
So we've been talking
the past few weeks now
on web development,
web deployment.
And that really gave you
a taste of at least some
of the tools and some
of the procedures
that you may face if you
find yourself in a software
development or a software
engineer role in your future.
So that was kind of one
exposure to a job title.
But now we're going to
pivot to a different one.
So we've talked security jobs,
we've talked development jobs.
And now we're going to talk
database and database management
jobs, and so really,
again, the tools and skills
that you may be exposed to.
We're not going to
cover everything.
There's courses, whole
courses dedicated to this.
Again, many of you
probably have already
taken courses related
to database work.
So a lot of this should
be refresher as far
as what a database is.
We're not going to
talk too much on that.
But either way, you've
probably seen them
in some capacity before, likely
on your local machine, or maybe
on a network or shared network.
But again, we're
going to talk today
about using them in the cloud.
And so what tools are out there?
What options do
we have out there?
How do we do this deployment?
Why would we want to choose
one tool versus another?
And then we'll go from there.
| again, like I said,
plenty of options out there
to explore this topic further.
We should even have a
data warehousing course
that will be focused on
cloud-based work in the spring
semester.
So if you're interested in that,
definitely look at taking that.
It'll be a great course, and
you'll learn so much more
than you're going to learn these
four or five lectures we're
going to do on this topic.
So either way, with that, let's
jump right into it and at least
start exposing you
to these ideas.
So let's shrink out the way.
And so to start with, I guess
I'll give a brief aside.
If you haven't seen
a database before,
think of a database at
its core, kind of just
like a spreadsheet, right?
It has rows.
It has columns.
Those columns represent some
characteristic about those rows.
Those rows are maybe sales
or users or locations.
Anything about your
company, your business,
your project that
you're working on you
might store it in a database.
And specifically, you might
be looking at storing it
in a relational database.
And we'll, I think, only talk
about relational databases
in this course.
What we mean by
that is really we
can match relationships
between tables and things.
So if I have a user table, I
could also have a sales table
and map those sales
back to that user,
Right I have actual
relationships between those.
And so some considerations
we'll have to have for that,
if we're thinking-- again,
we're on the cloud side now.
We're having this
cloud deployment.
So what are the
considerations for that?
Main thing, server maintenance
and energy footprint, right?
We're going to have to
maintain these products.
Oh, here Let me
turn my light on.
Supposed to have a
little more light on me.
We're going to have to maintain
these products, these servers
that we have live.
That's going to be both
physical and your hardware-
and software-based maintenance.
And that software-based
maintenance
really comes in the second
bullet point with software
installation and patches.
But then also we have to
consider the energy footprint,
right?
How much energy is going to be
needed to power our servers?
And what is the reliability
of our energy source?
So again, if you think
about your company,
if you have on-premise service--
this is kind of
the original core
question we talked
about in this course is,
if I have on-premise
servers, I am
going to be at risk
of downtime associated
with any sort of
natural disasters
that might happen at
my locations, right?
That's why we want to leverage
this global infrastructure
of AWS, right?
That's their whole
branding, their whole pitch
for why you should consider
it, and energy footprint
being one of those.
You also need to handle
the database backups
and the availability
of that, making sure
that it's always working.
It's always ready to go, even if
there are some updates, right?
Maybe that means I need to have
a duplicate copy of my database.
So now I need to have
twice as many servers
as I do data at all times.
So that means I need to, then,
if I have a bunch of more
data coming in or we get
some new data source that all
of a sudden significantly
increases my requirements,
now I need to scale, right?
So I need to order more
hardware, which hopefully you're
not in a pandemic where you
have part shortages for servers.
There you might have
indefinite lead times.
You might not know when those
next servers will be available
and they can get to
your warehouse, which
might limit the
business that you can do
and how fast your
company can grow.
And then finally, data security.
And I guess we kind of already
talked installation patch,
so maybe I need to reduce that
or remove that bullet point.
But really, you could argue
that the OS updates are
arguably separate from any
of the software that you
might have on your
computer directly, right?
Though, arguably OS is a
software, but either way,
the security is for
sure still a concern.
So if now all of a sudden
there are vulnerabilities
in that operating
system, let's say,
that become known
for whatever reason--
you're just using a Windows
server maybe or a Linux server
or some specific
flavor of Linux,
and then some security
vulnerability becomes known.
Now I need to take
all my servers down
to push those updates.
How does that
impact my business?
impact my workflow?
Does that limit my employees
and how they're doing,
what they're doing that day?
So all of these are major,
major considerations just
from the standpoint
of well, we want
to have a database that we host.
And so that is kind
of the main thing
we're keeping in the
back of our minds
with why we want to
pivot to the cloud.
And so the two things
we'll talk about--
and this is both relevant for
cloud and on-premise solutions,
but really, again, we're going
to be thinking about this
in the context of cloud
projects or cloud solutions-- is
that there are unmanaged and
there are managed solutions.
Unmanaged solutions are
exactly like they say, right?
We are the ones in
control of everything.
Think of the infrastructure
as a service, right?
Yeah, as a service.
So if I have an EC2 instance,
that's effectively unmanaged.
If I need to increase the
capacity of my EC2 instance,
I have to go in and manually
increase that, or at least write
some code that will
increase that capacity.
If there are faults, if
there's is availability issues,
I am again in charge of
making sure that those all
come back up online.
There's no downtime.
There's no issues with
my customers' data.
There's no leakage
of their data, right?
I'm now beholden
to ensuring that I
have secure control over that.
So it's completely unmanaged.
Now, benefits is while
you have complete control
of the infrastructure,
which is maybe
a drawback in some
situations, it
can also be a huge
benefit, right?
First off, once you've got
the equipment paid off,
it's paid off, right?
Those costs are now amortized
across the life of that tool.
So if you, for
whatever reason, are
a heavy user of
specific resources
and you know that
there's not going
to be an issue of needing
to scale past that capacity,
but you need to hit it hard
and every day, then maybe you
will have a benefit, a
cost benefit to having
some on-premise
solutions, or better said,
some unmanaged solutions, right?
I can completely control.
Because really, even
with the EC2 instance,
I have complete
control of what set up.
When things are spun
up, I don't have
to worry that all of a
sudden just because there's
a bunch of traffic
to my website,
it spiked beyond what I
would have been comfortable
with it actually doing as
far as spinning up resources.
So major benefit.
And arguably even more is we can
airgap those solutions, right?
With a true unmanaged
and on-premise service,
I have no connection
to the internet
and still be completely
able to utilize it,
depending on if it needs
to hit the internet.
But assuming it's all data
that's being used locally,
then I can airgap
it So. if it's very
secure, sensitive information,
this can be absolutely critical.
So working with an
unmanaged service where
I don't have to worry
that there's something
in the loop there that might be
interfering with it is critical.
Now, on the managed
side of things,
I would argue that the benefits
are really just the set it
and forget it, right?
I don't have to
think about anything.
I tell AWS or whatever managed
service I'm using to say,
hey, I want to
have this database.
I don't want to worry
about anything else.
I don't want to scale it.
I don't want worry about
security backups, any of that.
I just want to check a box
that says, do it for me.
And that is the benefit of
a managed service, right?
And there's a lot
of value to that.
Imagine you're starting
a small business
and you're working on some
other aspect of the business,
but you really have database
that you need to make sure
is still secure and scalable.
Great.
Use a managed service.
You can limit the amount of
dollars spent on employees just
to manage resources that can be
automatically handled, right?
That's the whole goal
with this, is to leverage
that for our benefit.
So it's beneficial.
And we're going to mostly
talk on the front of managed
services, but we'll start off
on the unmanaged side of things,
just as we did with the website.
And maybe that's a good
context to think about it in.
When we built our
website, we started
with completely
unmanaged services.
We said, let's just build it
all ourselves right directly
on top of an EC2 instance.
We didn't even use any sort of
application or app framework
like Flask.
We just built the raw--
or hosted the raw HTML.
But then eventually, we
saw how to do it in Heroku.
We saw how to deploy
our API via Docker.
So we saw all these
different solutions
that were, by construction,
managed solutions.
So there is a general
push to whenever
you've got a
process figured out,
it's really ideal to move
towards a managed solution
so you're not thinking about it
and wasting man hours for that.
So if we follow the continuum
from on-premises database
up to database in Amazon RDS,
or Amazon Aurora, like we have
on this far righthand side here,
you can think of that blue box
as again, just expanding
to what AWS is providing,
what they're going to control.
So if we go with a completely
on-premises database,
we've got everything
start to finish, right?
We have to control every
aspect of those servers outside
of building the server
itself, to some extent,
or at least the
components in the server.
You might still be
assembling the server rack.
If you move, then, to hosting
a database on an EC2 instance,
which we'll do, then you'll
see that OK, well, you still
have to manage quite a
bit of stuff-- scaling,
availability, backups, patches,
software installs, OS patches.
But you don't really have
to handle the initial OS
install, the general
maintenance of the servers,
the power, the cooling
of those servers, again,
cooling being a huge,
huge part of it.
I think I told that story
about one of our data
centers flooding at one
of my previous jobs.
One of the AC units leaked
or something like that.
And the water was slowly
creeping towards our servers,
and that is obviously not ideal.
So keeping that
in mind, that you
don't have to worry about
that in those kind of outages,
is a huge benefit, even if
you're just doing that approach.
And then finally, on the
most extreme end outside
of optimizing your individual
application, which again is just
doing your coding
side of things,
everything else is going to
be completely managed by AWS,
right?
They're going to
manage the scaling
availability, backups software.
And that's assuming
again, that you're
using one of their managed
like Amazon RDS or Amazon
Aurora, which we'll talk
about what those mean.
But that is the kind
of extreme end of it,
of you're not touching anything.
They've got it all
taken care of for you.
So then onto what RDS is.
So it stands for Relational
Database Service.
So you might even have
recognized that acronym before.
It's a pretty general
purpose acronym.
But specifically we're going
to be talking about Amazon RDS.
And so the basic
building block of RDS
is the database
instance itself, right?
That is what the one
thing we need to define
is, what is this database
instance, and really,
what does it look like?
So it's just a
database environment.
It can contain multiple
user-created databases.
It's just the
environment in which
these databases are hosted.
And you can choose amongst
these database engines.
These are the ones that
are built into Amazon RDS.
You can't really-- at
least as far as I'm aware,
you can't bring in
any other flavors
of a database
engine for yourself
that you may have
been using already.
You're kind of
constrained to using this,
but that's also because,
again, it's a managed service.
So they need to write all the
code on the back end for them
to handle the scaling, the
backups, availability, patching,
and all that good stuff.
So you're constrained to
what you can use with--
Amazon Aurora being an actual
first-party Amazon solution,
and the other's coming
from other sources.
But either way, that usually
covers most of the industry.
I personally have only ever
worked with the top three there,
but I know that you
all have probably
been exposed to Oracle,
depending on what course you've
taken to this, or Postgres.
So again, for most
companies and organizations,
this is sufficient.
But be mindful that
you are constrained
to these six database engines.
But you can control your CPU,
memory, network performance.
You can set max amounts on
memory and CPU consumption
and what network performance
is actually absolutely needed
for your task.
So if it's not needing
top-end specs of everything,
then save that money and get
the minimum solution, right?
That'll depend on your
business use case,
and that's something
for you to think about.
But that's what
we're saying there.
So the way it's--
or better said, one
way it can be hosted
is in a virtual
private cloud, right?
Remember, VPC stands for
Virtual Private Cloud.
And so that is just a
completely isolated environment
of the AWS cloud for you or
your organization to work in.
It's completely
logical isolation.
Now, it can-- yeah, I'm pretty
sure your availability zone can
stretch, or your VPC can stretch
across multiple availability
zones.
But it still is,
again, treating it
as a logically independent
portion of the cloud.
So it's for you only.
You have to choose
who has access to it.
So you can see here you have
to create this internet gateway
to provide access
to those resources.
You can create your
own IP address range--
sorry, I'm talking
too fast today--
create subnets, configure the
routing access control lists.
Again, access control lists
will control who can access.
Oh, yeah.
And then I gave
this example here
that the database
instance is often
isolated in a private
subnet, meaning
that really nobody is or
should be directly accessing
it, the private subnet
that's sitting down here that
houses our RDS instance.
Instead, we will provide access
to specific users' applications
to the resources
necessary in that.
But again, common practice,
principles of least privilege,
or minimum privilege,
whatever, just because we
want to ensure that nobody's
unnecessarily writing,
reading, or even worse, deleting
from this database, right?
So these are all considerations
that we can have,
and you can leverage
this in a VPC.
Oh, yeah, there we go.
So, yeah, you can
see that we can
do a VPC in multiple
availability zones.
A common reason
you'd want to do this
is imagine you are an
international company,
if you have locations in San
Francisco, Logan, and Hong Kong.
And you want your employees,
who are data scientists or data
analysts, whatever, whoever
needs to access this database,
maybe even just an
application that's
running at those
locations, you don't
want them to have to really wait
on the data transfer speeds to--
if they have a
query in Hong Kong
and the data is
hosted in Logan, you
don't want them to have
to wait the extra lag
time of sending that query
all the way across the world
and then back across once
they have a response.
Instead, you can create this
second availability zone
for your database, where
basically the transactions,
the individual rows, those
get rep synchronously.
So as they come in, they
get replicated to the copy.
And so because of that, you'll
have this second version here,
where if they make
a query, they're
just going to hit this query in
their closest availability zone.
It's up to date.
Even though there's
a time for the data
to transfer from wherever
its original location is
over to here, that's going
to only have to happen once.
It's not every single
query that happens
has to go all the way across.
So we're going to save
on transfer speeds.
We're just going to save
costs, time, resources,
all that good stuff.
Another benefit of this is
that if the main database
fails, right?
Imagine this M here
represents our main database.
If that main database
fails, then RDS
will automatically bring
the standby instance
online as the main instance.
Even if you're just doing
a planned maintenance,
planned system maintenance--
I need to update the OS
or the security patch
or something like
that-- well, great.
I can take this instance down.
I can just shut down
this main instance,
make the private subnet the
main instance-- or sorry,
the private subnet,
the second availability
zone the main instance and
then do my updates here.
Once this is done, switch it
back to being the main instance,
and I can do my updates here.
So I kind of have an
ongoing backup here.
So the multi-availability zone
approach has a lot of benefits,
and definitely recommend if it
is a tool or a solution that
presents itself whenever you
find yourself in that position
to make a decision.
Similar to that is
creating a read replica--
here I can kind of duck out of
the way, read replica instance.
And it does exactly
what it sounds like.
So it takes the--
or better statement,
it allows the load on the source
database, the original database,
to be reduced by
just routing queries
to this other database that is
just for reading from, right?
So think about the
use case here, right?
You have data scientists.
And we actually had a
similar situation to this
at Carvana, right?
We as data scientists
are constantly
writing the worst big queries
to grab and join and reduce
and filter out observations to
create a new data set or maybe
a temp table or
something like that.
But at the same time,
people are constantly
interacting with the
website as well, which
is generating new data points.
And so if I first off,
kick off a query that
maybe is running
live, it might never
end if the statements are
coming in fast enough to keep it
persisting.
Or even worse, I can just kind
of bottleneck the server such
that with my big query, I can
bottleneck the server such
that it can't start
to collect new data.
So I might miss out on
sales or anything else,
or just create a bad
experience for the user
because the user
hits the website
and they can't pull
up any of the vehicles
because the databases are
overloaded with my stupid query
that I wrote.
So this is the idea
behind a read replica,
is that, well, I'll just
create a replica of the data
at some sort of regular cadence.
You can see here I can do it
in a different region, which
will allow for more
disaster recovery
if there's an issue with
that or a worry with that.
And yeah, I never have to
worry about clogging up
this main or primary
database instance.
And so I just create this
read replica, read from that.
Or any read queries
will read from there.
And then everything can still be
updating in my primary instance.
And then at some regular cadence
we just update the read replica.
It could even be
synchronous, right?
And so then question is, when
to use RDS versus potentially
exploring other tools?
I would say for
most of your actions
as a student, or even
as early employee,
you likely won't be
doing things that are
exceeding the capacity of RDS.
But that's not
always true, right?
So just keep it in mind.
Complex transactions,
very complex queries,
it's maybe not the
most efficient.
Again, analytics teams can
really, a lot of times,
push the boundary of what's
an acceptable query for RDS
or one of these tools.
And that's where they may
want to explore something
like Redshift, which we'll
talk about in a little bit.
A medium to high
query or write rate,
which they deem as anything
up to 30,000 input/output
operations per second, 15,000
reads plus 15,000 writes,
anything that's at that scale
or kind of exceeding that scale,
you might want to look
at some other solutions.
That's a lot read and writes per
second, I'll say that, right?
15,000 read and write
operations per second,
I think it's going to be
OK for most of your usage,
but that's not to say
it's impossible, right?
There, again, very clearly,
many businesses that
are doing this, right?
If I'm working with
financial data,
I might be getting just
countless data points
per second, and I might be
doing a bunch of processing
and querying and
subsetting and creating
of new data sets on the fly.
And so I need this
to be running fast
and be able to have
significantly more IOPs.
And so that's where I
might not want to stick
with something like RDS, right?
And it's not even necessarily
that it's a managed solution,
so much as it's not designed
for these kind of high loads.
Oh, sorry, Was that
a misquote in there?
Oh, yeah, sorry.
Do not read.
I was reading this
lefthand side here.
It can handle complex queries,
but when these complex queries--
I was right actually in this.
When they start to exceed this,
when you're getting up to these
150,000 read/writes per second,
that's where you're starting
to exceed the capacity.
But it does have
high durability.
It can handle complex queries.
But I will maybe put an
asterisk on that next time
and say that I have pushed
beyond the capacity of what
you should do there.
So just keep that in mind.
But yeah, it can handle a lot.
But again, as these
read/write rates
start to climb
significantly, consider
exploring other options.
As well, if it's simple,
or a better statement,
it's not something
that's necessarily
needs to be relational,
like using a NoSQL database,
then great.
Don't waste your time
setting up everything
that goes along with a
relational database, right?
This is more of a
database design question
and outside the
scope of this course.
But just keep that in mind.
And then finally,
yeah, customization.
That's going to be the nature
of any managed service.
The customization
is usually going
to be limited by construction
because the goal is
to manage it,
constrain it, and keep
it easy to set up and spin up.
A few notes on billing for
RDS, mostly in case you're
curious or planning to look at
doing the AWS Cloud Practitioner
exam.
They do have questions
on all these things,
so I just wanted to dribble some
details in there occasionally.
But it is still
important to know,
in case you want to
build something out
like this for your final
project, for example.
And there is a
free tier as well.
And we'll see what the
free tier allows for.
But either way, the resources
will incur charges when running.
So once your data set or
database is live, it's running.
That is technically costing
them electricity, storage space.
They're going to
start charging you.
And then the physical capacity,
just as with the EC2 instance,
will determine the price.
Again, to some
extent, everything
is kind of built off of EC2
instances anyways, right?
It's just computers.
And so they still
similarly charge you
for engine, size, memory
class, all that good stuff.
And again, engine is because
there are certain products that
are more specialized and so
you're paying for that premium
experience.
And then just as
with EC2 instances,
you can choose between on-demand
and reserved instances.
So reserved instances
reduce that cost
and usually have a
one-time upfront payment.
But it's a cheaper
cost if you're
spreading across one
year or three-year terms.
So if you have a
big organization,
you're planning to
use this ongoing,
explore those
reserved instances.
And then finally, multiple
database instances
can be provisioned
to handle peak loads.
And so again, you're going
to be charged for those,
but you can still leverage
this kind of feature of AWS
such that you don't have to pay
for peak resources at all times.
You can just scale up
as necessary or when
those times come,
and you can still
put constraints on how many
instances, how big they can be,
and all that.
And as far as other cloud
database options go,
we will probably look
at Aurora and Redshift.
I don't think we'll
touch DynamoDB.
It's again, it's a
NoSQL database service,
but it's managed.
It supports key-value
document data structures.
So again, if that
means something to you,
if you are looking at doing
something where you're using--
or better statement, you can
better leverage a NoSQL database
than you can a relational
database service,
you'll know and look into it.
If not, can come
talk to me if you're
unsure of that difference.
But again, outside the
scope of this course.
I'm not super
worried about that.
We're going to
focus on the tools.
Or better statement,
we're going to focus
on the concept around how to
do what we're going to do here,
as opposed to the details
of why we want to pick
one tool versus another.
That's an entirely
different question,
and it's so problem dependent
that we can't really
cover them all in this course.
Aurora, though, is kind
of Amazon's textbook
built-for-the-cloud tool, so
higher throughput storage,
auto scaling, self-healing
fault tolerance storage system,
claimed huge speedup
improvements,
five times speed up over MySQL,
three times over PostgreSQL.
So value if you can go there
and you can leverage that.
It's a little bit more
expensive than using something
like a MySQL instance.
But if you want that extra
little bit of performance,
Aurora is a great option.
Or again, what
I've used more of--
you can kind of
see the logo there.
They all share the same family
of logos, but-- is Redshift.
And that is for high-performance
data warehousing,
designed for big data
analytic workloads.
And that's exactly how
we're using it, right?
We had websites streaming
data, so just countless data
points coming in
every second, way,
way too much for RDS or Aurora
or-- a better statement--
for it to be practical.
A big reason why that
is, or a big reason why
it's so effective for data
analytics workloads is it's
actually column oriented.
So if you think
about or if you've
been exposed to relational
databases before,
you know that everything is
kind of viewed at a transaction
level, right?
A row is really what
we're considering.
We're looking at individual
users, individual sales,
whatever that row is.
And so our queries are
really fast across rows.
But it's not really focused
on column-based operations
because you're not really
doing anything, right?
You're usually just returning
information constantly.
In analytics, it's
entirely different.
So if you've done any Python
outside of this course
and you've leveraged
something like pandas before,
that's a column-based
data storage tool.
If you've used R, the
coding language R before,
their data frames
are all column based.
And that's because again, I
probably want to do things
on the columns, right?
The columns are
my variables now.
And so maybe I want
to do something
as simple as averaging all the
values for a single variable.
Maybe I have the salaries
of all the employees
in the state of Utah.
And so I want to average
all of their salaries.
Well, I don't want to have
to wait for this really slow,
row-based operation to happen.
I just want to slam that column
in there and take the average.
And so that is how
Redshift is designed.
There's a lot that
goes into what
makes it column-
versus row-based,
or it's well
outside this course.
But that is the thing, or one
of the fundamental components
that makes Redshift so efficient
for these big data projects.
And then you can see
also that it just
allows significantly more data,
up to 16 petabytes of data
on a cluster.
So a petabyte is 1000
terabytes, something like that,
compared to only 128
terabytes on Aurora,
so many orders of
magnitude more data
allowed, or better
statement, data capacity
on Redshift versus Aurora.
So that is something to explore.
And we'll definitely
talk about Redshift
because, again, it's the one
I'm most comfortable with.
But we'll get into
that later on.
So I think that's it.
Yeah.
So I'll just say a
few things that--
or let me pull up my
notes here for a second.
That puts us now somewhere
around lecture 18--
or I think this will be lecture
17 maybe that's going live.
We're going to cover creating,
connecting to a MySQL database
next.
That'll be the next
thing coming up here.
And that'll be done
likely on EC2 instance.
And then we'll
look at leveraging
some more of these managed
services, like RDS and Redshift.
And so we'll play
around with all this.
We'll teach you how to
get everything set up,
and then we'll go from there.
And you should see an assignment
associated with this as well,
too.
And so check that out.
And, yeah, I'll
catch you next time.
Shoot me an email if
you have any questions
or any concerns about things.
Thanks.
Bye.